Tim Ferriss:
Dr. Volkow, it is lovely to see you. Thank
you for making the time to be on the show.
Thanks for being here.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Tim,
it's a pleasure. Thanks for having me.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. And I wanted to
say before we launch into the full conversation,
a sincere thanks to you and the
entire NIDA team because I have
found addiction to be very near and dear to me in
the sense that my uncle died of alcohol-induced
cardiomyopathy. One of my aunts died of alcohol
and Percocet as an overdose. One of my best
friends growing up died of a fentanyl overdose.
So this is a subject that I think,
not surprisingly to anyone listening, is
incredibly important and I've just had the
opportunity to see it in very close quarters. So
I wanted to start with just thanking you for doing
the work that you do. So that's step number one.
And I thought then I would take a very hard left
turn and ask you about cadavers. Specifically,
I read that when you were quite young, you asked
your father if you could bring a cadaver
home to dissect. His answer was yes. And
that his answer was generally yes to anything
science-related. Could you just flesh this story
out a little bit, provide a little more context?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Absolutely. And first of all, I'm
sorry for the loss of your family, relatives and
your friend. I mean, it is very tragic and that's
why I mean, I'm so devoted to the whole subject
because it shouldn't be. I mean, people shouldn't
be dying from addictions and yet they do. And
there are many factors that if we could change
then we wouldn't be losing these lives.
So then let me jump into the question that
you call left-side or right-sided. My father
is a scientist and so he was obsessed of having
his daughters, he didn't have a son, so he
was obsessed of having the daughters going
to science. And I was the one that, I have
another sister who was then in high school,
but I was the one in medical school, and I
wanted to do research. And I was absolutely
fascinated by the human body and anatomy.
And I just marvel about the beauty of how our
bodies are constructed. So in the classes we have
to take anatomy and we had to dissect actually,
basically dissection on people who have died,
on corpses. But I didn't have enough time,
and I wanted, I'm very obsessive. Whenever
I do things, I do them compulsively. So I
wanted to be able to do that right.
And based on the time limits that we
have at school, it was going to be impossible.
We would be able to, each one of us dissect,
for example, one extremity. And so
I asked my father if I could bring
a corpse that I could do autopsy. And
my father had a laboratory in the house,
and he said yes. But then my mother and
my sisters rebelled and said, "If Nora
brings a corpse into the house for her anatomy
classes, then we are leaving the house." That was
very categorical. I lost, that's it. No more.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to come back to the
obsessive focus and following the trail where
it leads. I'm going to come back to that. But
before I do, perhaps you could just describe
where you grew up, where you were at the time,
and how someone or a family with the last name
Volkow, which to most people would perhaps
bring up connotations of certain types
of origins, end up in where you ended up
in terms of your formative years.
Dr. Nora Volkow: I was born in Mexico City. I went
to medical school in Mexico City. And it was until
I was finishing medical school that I left Mexico
to go to Paris, then to the jungle. And then I
went to New York for my training in psychiatry.
And the reason why, actually I ultimately
was born in Mexico City. It's interesting,
it's driven by, I always say, the belligerent
nature of men. Because my father is the grandson
of Leon Trotsky. And the only place that gave
political asylum to Leon Trotsky was Mexico.
And my mother who was born in Madrid, ended
up in Mexico because also Mexico was the place
that gave asylum to the children and of the
people that were fighting against Franco in
Madrid. So Madrid was going to be bombarded by the
Franco forces, so the government of Mexico, in an
attempt to save those children, offered asylum
to the children to be brought from Madrid into
Mexico, at the care of the Mexican government.
And so that's how the two families came together.
My father came to Mexico as an orphan because
Trotsky basically had taken the responsibility of
him. His mother had committed suicide. His father
had been sent to a concentration camp by Stalin.
And so the only relative that he had was Trotsky.
So he came to Mexico because that was his family.
And he was 12 years old when he came to Mexico.
And that's how he ended up in Mexico. My mother
came to Mexico when she was 18 years of age,
coming with her family to look for her two
brothers who had come as little children as part
of the asylum to the children that were in Madrid.
And they met, and that's how fortuitous history
is. They met, fell in love, and then they had
four daughters and I was the second one of them.
And we actually lived in the house where Trotsky
had been killed because my father took the
responsibility to ensure that the house where
Trotsky lived will be left as a museum so that
there would be a historical memory of what tyranny
can do, the tyranny of Stalin and basically the
extermination of all of his enemies, which of
course Trotsky was of his, one of his main ones.
And he basically aimed to destroy the family of
Trotsky up to the third generation, which would
have ended with my father. But it would have ended
up with us, actually the third generation is us.
And they tried to kill my father and my father
was a little child, but they didn't succeed.
So and then by my time I was born, which is
the third generation, no one has tried to kill
me fortunately too, not from the Stalin era,
but I shouldn't be so flippant about it. I
mean, it's a very serious issue. And of course
it has followed our family. And at one point
when I was a medical student, I wanted to go
to Russia to study because, and I was given a
scholarship. And my father really freaked out.
And at that point is when I was basically made
aware and said, "Nora, you cannot do that.
You're also going to be putting your father
in a very awkward position because he can be
basically blackmailed." And there is this curse
that Stalin had said that he would persecute up
to the third generation. And that's how I ended
up in Mexico City and where I went to school
and until I did my training in psychiatry.
Tim Ferriss: So I would love to expand on
this just a little bit for people who may not
recognize the name Leon Trotsky. So number one,
we won't go into a huge Wikipedia page on
Leon Trotsky, but people should read the
basics and find him online. Very historically
notable, very important, as you mentioned, as
opposition of sorts with respect to some
very powerful figures in Soviet history.
And he also, based on my reading,
please correct me if I'm wrong,
but survived multiple assassination attempts and
then was finally killed, but not immediately,
by someone with an ice axe that penetrated
his head by something like seven centimeters,
but still managed to subdue with his guards, the
attacker. And he just seems like such a force of
nature and such a powerful figure to begin
with. And so to have that in your lineage,
I would just be so curious to know how all of that
has informed, if you feel like it has, the way you
relate to the world, or even think about history
or voicing your own opinion, anything like that.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yeah, absolutely. And there's no
way it doesn't influence you. And be aware that as
a little girl, I was living in that house. And so
I was surrounded by not just the knowledge that it
was my father's grandfather and I had basically,
well, until I was seven, eight years old, I also,
his second wife was living in the house,
Natalia, who became a very dear person to me.
So when you are born into a house where
you know that you have a relative that did
something that was very motivated towards
improving the best, the next generations,
the chances that next generations had, that they
were committed to a more just and fair society,
that is ingrained into your brain.
And both my parents were very systematic
making us aware that we do have a responsibility
that each one of us as an individual,
you should be recognized that we are part of a
social system where how you act has consequences
and that your acts can actually significantly
improve or negatively affect the life of others.
So we, all of us, my three sisters and I, have
that very much ingrained into our motivation
and how we live our lives. And so for me that
has been crucial. So I become very, I mean,
particular. And this is something I've always had.
I very sensitive to people, the most vulnerable.
I mean, it just generates this drive and trying to
help, trying make I very intolerant of injustices.
I've always been. And so it drives me crazy.
It activates my amygdala when I see someone
improperly treated. And obviously as you grow up
and you have different, you find yourselves in
positions where you say, "What can I do to help?"
And that has ultimately led me to take this
position of, took me to take the position of
director of the National Institute on Drug Abuse
because I realized that it would put me in a
leadership position where I could influence
the knowledge that was derived in order to affect
policies that would lead to a better opportunity
for people suffering from substance use disorder.
So that's fundamental to me. And that came from my
historical background and upbringing.
Tim Ferriss: What did your father
feel the role or responsibility of scientists
was? I'm wondering, I suppose why he said yes
to most things or all things science related.
Maybe he said yes to most things for you. I
have no idea. But if it happened to be
pretty specific to science, why did he
do that? Why was it important in his mind?
Dr. Nora Volkow: I think a lot about it because
my father, when we were growing up, he would
never, ever speak about Trotsky and we were
not allowed to ask questions because it was felt
that it was just too painful for him to speak up.
And the first time he did an interview about his
experience with Trotsky was when I was, I think I
must have been 17 years of age or 16 years of age.
And that was a turning point for him where he
started to speak about it. And I think my father,
an extraordinary individual, I mean, with an
amazing resilience, was using certain mechanism to
try to deal with the suffering. I mean, his mother
committed suicide when he was living with her.
He lost his father to a concentration camp. His
sister was left behind in Russia because Stalin
did not allow his mother to take, yeah, basically
only allowed him to take one of the two
children. And so the mother selected the
one that was younger, which was my father.
And then while when he loses the mother,
he goes and lives with an uncle and the
uncle is killed by Stalin while in Paris.
And then he ends up with Trotsky, and Trotsky's
assassinated. And basically my father is coming
into the house when Mercader, who's the killer is
inside and he hears him, "Don't let Seva — which
is the name of my father — see me." So he has the
clarity of mind to recognize he doesn't want my
father to see him all covered in blood. So if
you think about what it must mean for a child
to go these, all of these experiences, I think
you have to develop mechanism of protection.
And in that respect, my view is that science
provides it because science tends to be very
black and white. I mean it's not really black
and white. I mean, the physical sciences,
mathematical sciences are black and white.
Biology is more graded, but you can extract
objective information that is reproducible.
And I think that gives you a sense of solidity.
And I think that this may be one of the reasons
why my father was so attracted to science. And
what I can tell you, he was very categorical. He
did not want any one of his daughters to go into
politics. He was black and white, no politics.
And his perspective was that the family already
had paid a very, very big price because of
politics. And so he really didn't want to.
So in that respect, of course, science offered
this ideal profession where people were driven
by looking and trying to understand the truth
of things in objective ways, where there was not
that subjective element where things can creep
in and rapidly be influenced by one person's
perspective. Now, this is me speculating about
why my father was so driven into the science.
It may just be that he loved science for
because it's a fantastic field. Science is
basically you're moving your curiosity to try to
understand the world and they pay you for it. So
it's a great —. So I am making a speculative leap
because I have thought about it like you sort of
asked me. But at the same time I have to recognize
that it may also just be that he loved science
because he's a curious, very curious person.
Tim Ferriss: I'd love to look at other influences
in your thinking and trajectory. And the name I
would like to invoke is Julian Villarreal. And I
did check the pronunciation before we started
for people wondering. And I would love to know
who this person was and what influence
he had on you. If you could describe.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Julian was a pharmacologist
that was working in a pharmaceutical company.
And he was a physician and a PhD in pharmacology
who had gone to Michigan University for his PhD.
And I ended up with him because as a medical
student, I knew I wanted to do research. And
so I started to volunteer with actually one of the
major scientists in Mexico, Tamayo, who was doing
work on autopsies and tissue pathologists.
He was a pathologist. And he said, "Nora,
you like behavior, you like drugs, you like the
brain. Let me introduce you to someone that will
basically have better background than mine."
And so he introduced me to Julian Villarreal.
And immediately, I hit it off with Julian.
And what intrigued me so much about Julian
was that he was a — he thought outside the box
completely. And that resonated totally with me.
And he was interested at that time, his
research was on trying to understand what
were the mechanisms that account for the
tolerance to opioids and the mechanisms
that account for the withdrawal that emerges when
someone becomes physically dependent to opioids.
And his idea was that if you have these models and
you could understand them, then you would be able
to develop an opioid medication that would not
be addictive, that would not produce tolerance,
that could not produce withdrawal. And many
pharmacologists went into that whole field.
And certainly what I can tell you as of
now, no one has succeeded on getting an
opioid medication that is not addictive and
that doesn't produce tolerance or withdrawal.
But the models that he was using and the way
that he was challenging me, which was very, very
quantitative, he was always trying to figure out
a way of quantifying behavior in animals that then
could be used to predict the responses to drugs.
Tim Ferriss: How did Julian
encourage you to think differently?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Well, he was introducing
me to a lot of the analytical methods to be able
to define variables. I realize this was very much
before its time. Right now, for example, a lot of
the analysis that we do employs vectors as a means
to actually describe a trajectory of something
more than one point. And he was introducing me
to those technologies and says, "Nora, learn about
it," and he would give me books, "So that you can
try to see how you apply them to the measures
you are taking on the animal experiments."
So he opened, in my brain, the whole curiosity
of using quantitative analysis in ways beyond
the traditional, very simplistic statistical
methods that we use. And this is something that,
now, is fundamental for the type of work that we
are doing, in many fields of science. But for me,
as someone that is in neurosciences and
neuroimaging, it is crucial to basically enable us
to understand and to actually integrate databases
that are very, very diverse and distinct.
So that, I owe to Julian. He would challenge
me. He would basically give me questions that
would make me think, and that's what I like.
And actually, he taught me that. And this is
something that I, as a mentor now, of young
scientists, I put them in positions where I
force them to think and to think differently. And
for example, one of the questions, I always go,
you have students and postdocs, and they present
me the data, and I ask them, "Well, what do you
make of it?" And they give me an explanation,
and I said, "Okay, now, I want you to give me
the most outrageous explanation that you can get
me of this data," in order to force them to think
differently. Because there is a predictive element
in a lot of the things that is a reflection of the
influence of others. And I want that innovative
way, that association that others have not done,
I want to encourage them to play with it.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Because as a mentor,
especially a mentor who is highly respected by
your mentees or postdocs or whoever it might be,
it would be very easy to correct them
and perhaps, in some respects, force your
perspective on them. But that doesn't
help them develop the muscle of thinking
differently in the way that you're describing
by asking those types of probing questions,
which makes all the sense in the world.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yeah. But there's also
a selfish component into it. I think, for me,
it is totally uninteresting to hear a response
that I already would have thought myself. And
I think that brains work better when you expose
them to unexpected stimuli. So actually, I think
that scientific creativity is enriched by having
that basically playing with ideas and concepts.
And I encourage it a lot. And so we have team
meetings where I really probe them for people
to get into those spaces. And so it's crucial
that you empower them, you make them feel actually
confident, because otherwise, people don't dare.
They feel intimidated that they may say something
that others will think it's stupid. And that's so
very common when you are in groups. People don't
want to be seen as saying something that will
make them feel embarrassed. And to me, I always
actually start meetings and says, "Look, guys,
we are here to basically push the limit. So please
do not feel embarrassed. If you don't speak up,
we'll never have an opportunity to understand
where that idea may go through." So it's
something I always push. Whether it is with
people are my mentors or I'm organizing it
with experts, I do like to get that going.
Tim Ferriss: So you have a well-established
history, I would say, of pushing the limits and
knowing when to push. So I would like to just
read something I found from The Washington Post.
It's just a few paragraphs, and then I'll ask a
question related to it. Here we go. "In 1984,
she," that is you, "left NYU for an assistant
professorship at the University of Texas Health
Science Center at Houston, expecting to continue
her research." And then, they're quoting you.
"'They had a fantastic imaging center,' Volkow
recalls, but as it happens, "there wasn't a single
schizophrenic in the university hospital." What
the hospital did have was cocaine addicts." So you
adapted. And I'll summarize a little bit here or
just abbreviate, but you said, "'I was probably
the first person to use these new technologies
for the investigation of drugs of abuse,'
she says, but her work was ignored initially,
especially her seminal paper documenting
strokes in the brains of cocaine abusers."
And then, this is a quote of you, "'I
started to present these data at meetings,
and people didn't believe it, because there was
no evidence that cocaine was toxic,' she says.
'That's fine,' I said, 'because this is what the
data show.' She applied for a grant from NIDA."
Of course, everything comes full circle, but
"She applied for a grant from NIDA to pursue
her research and was turned down; it took three
years before The British Journal of Psychiatry
finally published her paper." And then, the
closing quote from you in this section is, "'This
is what happens when you come up with things
before their time.'" And my question for you is,
what was the experience like? And what was your
inner talk like going through this sequence of
events and having people dismiss, having people
reject, over that period of time, what was that
like for you? And how did you keep going?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Well, I'm a very perseverant
person, and I never give up. So sort of
my perspective is on this issue has always
been like that. And that finding, actually, I'm
still working on that to try to understand why,
how cocaine affects and producing these
strokes and how we can prevent them and
how we can help people. But at that time,
I was very young, and you have this sense
of you trust the system and you believe,
"Well, maybe I'm not good enough." And
we haven't consolidated the belief in yourself,
because you just basically recently trained. No
one had used that technology, and at that
point, there was this belief that cocaine
was safe. So here comes this person and showing
these data on images that others had never seen,
and with the background that cocaine
was, at that time, felt to be safe.
And I submitted it to The New England Journal
of Medicine, which is the most important medical
journal, clinical medical journal. They review
it, and they came back again saying, "Well,
there's really no evidence that cocaine
can be damaging to the blood vessels."
They were completely wrong. And now, it's
clear. All of that is history. No one will
question that cocaine, as well as other stimulant
drugs, produces vascular damage and pathology.
But it is the way that science goes. And you
sort of say science should be guided by data,
but science has a religious nature to it also. And
once a model is created, it becomes very difficult
to change it. And it takes a long, long time for
concepts that have been consolidated, as accepted
as the truth, to be questioned. And I see it. It
happened to me there, but I see it constantly.
And that statement that I say, that I stated
there, is very, very valid. If you come up
with something that it's ahead of its time, you're
going to have trouble getting it accepted, and you
may not actually necessarily be recognized for it.
When it becomes everyday life, then, other people
say, "Well, what's the big deal?" But yeah, that's
in the nature of the scientific progress. But as
someone that is directing and allocating
resources for science, I am very sensitive
to ensure that, if there are situations where
there may be something that is very innovative,
that others are not seeing, that we don't curtail
it. So I tend to, in many instances, say, "Okay,
let's give it the benefit of the doubt, because
if it is correct, it's going to be much more
transformative than if we just continue doing
science, that follows the rules of the game very,
very precisely, where, basically, what
you're expecting, you've already seen." So
I do think that we need to push the limits. And
with open access to scientific databases, this is
happening more and more, which is very exciting.
Tim Ferriss: Now, as you mentioned, you have
perseverance as a superpower. It is just a
statement of reality that you don't stop. And some
people may not have that, constitutionally. When
you are mentoring or having conversations with,
say, younger scientists who are facing their
first pushback, they're getting rejected, they're
having to try again and again, maybe they're
feeling demoralized. What do you say to them?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Well, basically, I say "This
happened to me." My first grant was basically just
redlined, totally and absolutely. And I was very
depressed. And at that time actually, people in
the institute at NIDA said "Nora, try again." And
I was in that respect. And again, I do not take no
for an answer. And this is a message that I say
to young people, "You should dare to do things.
And no one has the right to say, 'You cannot
bring a new perspective into things.'"
And so I always say, "Be daring and persevere."
Just with all of my postdoc students,
they get rejected on a paper, they get rejected
on a grant. The answer is just "Stand up and jump
back on the horse." It's just as simple as that.
Tim Ferriss: And for those who aren't watching
any video, you are very tough. You're very
physically fit, you're very mentally fit,
and you walk the walk. So I want to just
give people further evidence that you very
much walk that walk. And I'm going to segue
now to perhaps a discussion of the difference
between studying compounds and experiencing
compounds. And I was hoping you could tell the
story of how you became acquainted with Demerol.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yeah, that's interesting, because
I love Demerol. I probably shouldn't be saying
these things, but what happened to me, I was in a
horrible car accident. And I was the passenger,
and there was one of those hits that the car,
it was, I see the car does a 90 degree flip, and
the car in the opposite direction comes in and
strikes me in the passenger seat. Seeing the car
coming to me, I did not want my brain to be hit by
a car. And so, I said, "Okay." I put my foot into
the car to protect my head and to get my head as
far away as I could from the door, because I saw
it coming. And so I did not get hit in the head,
fortunately, but the door came crashing. And I
was trapped. My leg was trapped. It was broken.
I was under a lot of pain, and I wanted to lose
consciousness because the pain was so intense.
And so, finally, they had to come up with
the jaws of life to open up the door,
because they couldn't get me — they get me
into the ambulance, take me to the hospital,
and there, the doctor says, "Nora, we have to try
to move the fracture, so that we can accelerate
the healing. So otherwise, we're going to have
to go for surgery. So we are going to give you
Demerol." And they injected me with Demerol. It
was extraordinary. It was not just the intensity
of the suffering was disappearing — everything
was fascinating. And opioids make you sleepy.
And I was forcing myself not to sleep,
because everything was so extraordinary.
And so it gave me an insight of how powerful that
drug was, that, despite everything that was there,
I wanted to be aware of every sensation.
And they admitted me to the hospital,
and I had to spend there three days or two —
It was two nights and three days. And I recall
I was in the terrible pain, and they would give me
the Demerol. And it was this sense of well-being,
extraordinary sense of well-being from the opioid.
And that is the only time, really, that I've had
a real ability to have a consciousness
of how an opioid makes you feel.
And so, when they discharged me, they discharged
me on Monday, the accident was on Friday,
I was waiting on the car. And I felt
alchemical. Everything felt very unreal.
And the doctor had sent me home with two weeks
of medication for the pain, and I stopped cold
turkey. Lo and behold, I did have withdrawal over
the night, and it was so bad. I didn't understand,
at first, what was happening. I was restless.
It was worse than pain. And sometimes you need
to experience these things to understand it,
because you say, "What can be worse than pain?"
It was just I could not be comfortable, no matter
what. So I took one of the pills that he had given
me, and that was the last I took. And then,
the physical dependence that was responsible
for that withdrawal disappeared. And that's it.
That's my story with opioids, which made me very
aware that I do not want to be exposed to opioids
unless I have horrible pain. Because I can see
their allure. I can see how someone could easily
fall into that nirvana, that chemical nirvana,
that they create. And that's the story of
the Demerol. And that's why I say I did,
I have to be honest, it was an extraordinary
experience for me to have been able to feel what
it was. But it was also a very scary one.
Tim Ferriss: Super scary. I had nothing
nearly that severe, but I had a terrible
shoulder injury that ended up requiring
reconstruction. But in the emergency
room, when I ended up in the hospital,
they were overbooked, understaffed, they
had gunshot victims and so on, who took
precedence, of course. And so I was sitting there
with my arm dislocated, sort of sticking out of my
chest, for hours, and they gave me morphine. And I
remember thinking two things. The first was, "This
is incredible." The number two was, "I should
never, ever touch anything like this again."
And so, after my surgery, when they sent me home
and they gave me Vicodin and this, that, and the
other thing, they gave me a whole collection
of different painkillers. And fortunately,
some of them, I took for just a few days, and
they made me nauseous. And I was very happy that
they made me nauseous, because it made me less
likely to use them. But I do have a, I suppose,
a firsthand acquired fear, and then, a developed
fear, just from the experience of people in my
family and my friends. What is the current state?
How should people think about the current state
of addiction and overdose crises in the US?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Well, it's unfortunate. I
wish it were different, but it is in really
a state of very severe overdose deaths,
that are very difficult to control and regulate.
And what we are observing is that we are seeing
more and more people dying with very diverse
demographics from overdoses, which, again,
makes it so very hard to control. Because at
the beginning, the crisis started because we
started to overprescribe opioid medications.
And people diverted them. And people also,
who should have not been given them, because
they didn't have severe pain syndromes,
became addicted. And that opened up the door for
heroin. And then we started to see a rise in 2011,
more or less, of heroin injection, heroin and
people dying. And then, in 2016, there was a
transformative, very malignant change, which
was the introduction of fentanyl. And fentanyl,
we've all been hearing about it in the news.
It's a synthetic opioid that was developed in
order to have a more potent analgesic, and is
widely utilized in medicine for breakthrough
pain for cancer patients, for example. When the
medications that they have no longer controls the
pain, you can use fentanyl, but it's also
widely used by anesthesiologists. Because
when you combine fentanyl with an anesthetic, you
actually can control and regulate much better the
level of consciousness of your patients. So it's
a very useful drug, but it is, by its potency,
it is highly, highly addictive. It's also highly
dangerous, because of its potency, it can make you
stop breathing very, very rapidly. And it's a drug
that is very cheap to manufacture. You don't need
to cultivate any plant. You synthesize it. And
the synthesis is very simple. And because it's
so potent, you need 50 times less volume of drugs.
So you can bring it through the borders much more
easily than with heroin or any other drug that
we know of. And so it has both pharmacological
effects that make it dangerous, but also, the
production makes it actually very enticing for
the drug dealers. So they are incentivized
to distribute it. And that's what we've seen
accelerating during the COVID pandemic. Basically,
fentanyl permeated all of the country everywhere.
And so they started to also mix it with other
drugs, like cocaine or methamphetamine. And now,
more recently, with counterfeit pills that are
sold like Adderall, which is an amphetamine,
or like Ativan, which is a benzodiazepine
that you use for anxiety or sleep,
or even disguised as Vicodin, which is an opioid
medication for pain. They sell them on the web,
and they are less expensive than the real
thing. So people, it's not just that people
that are addicted to opioids can overdose.
Now, those that are taking cocaine can overdose.
Those that can take methamphetamine can overdose.
And students that may buy a pill in order to study
for an exam may overdose and die, because
the pill they got had fentanyl. Or a person
cannot get their physicians to prescribe them a
sleep medicine. They go and buy it on the web,
and they overdose. So this is the nature
of the major challenges that we have.
And we are seeing more and more new substances
emerging, which is like, again, running in a
treadmill, because we develop antidotes
for the overdoses from fentanyl. But now,
they are mixing fentanyl with an aesthetic that is
used in veterinary medicine, xylazine. And that,
actually, xylazine does not respond to Narcan,
which is the antidote that we use for fentanyl. So
this shifting nature of the drugs that people are
exposed to, the fact that they are increasingly
more potent, and the fact that they are basically
disguised in many ways, is expanding the number
of people that are now overdosing. And in some
instances, we don't have good strategies that we
can use to help them to revert those overdoses.
Tim Ferriss: It's such a complex evolving
ecosystem of compounds, and as you mentioned,
there's so many incidental or accidental ways
to ingest, for example, fentanyl.
And I know of many direct stories,
where people have gone to a bachelor
party, they try a little bit of some drug,
that ends up being cut with fentanyl. I know of
two people specifically. One just dropped dead on
the floor. One fell into a coma from what would've
been considered low doses of illicit drugs. But
they happened to be cut with fentanyl, which is
horrifying. And in fact, my friend who died was
not himself an addict. He was collateral damage.
One of my other friends I grew up with,
there are a lot of drug issues where I grew up,
was a heroin addict. He had developed just an
incredible tolerance to fentanyl, and he gave it
to my other friend to help with his hangover. And
my other friend had never used any opiates, and he
fell asleep and just never woke up. So the sheer
ease with which the fentanyl, as you mentioned,
sort of permeates different corners and
neighborhoods of society, which does not
discriminate in terms of — or I shouldn't say
it doesn't discriminate, but it has infiltrated
every socioeconomic class. It's really pervasive
and really terrifying. What is your perspective
on the War on Drugs and perhaps any other
approaches that you think may be more effective?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yeah. And I'll answer it,
but I guess actually the story that you just told
of your friend that how he'd be taking fentanyl
unbeknowing what it was, it just killed him. And
this is what we are observing a lot. And I think
it's important to educate people that this is
a seriously dangerous drugs. And unfortunately,
I think that we have cried wolf so many,
many times that we've lost credibility.
But if there was a way that we could convey
that in very objective, we don't need to
exaggerate in any way. I mean fentanyl, two
milligrams will kill you. And the counterfeit
pills contain five milligrams, some of them two
doses to kill you. So it is very, very tragic.
But coming back to your question in
terms of the War on Drugs, I think that
basically what it did was it created a mechanism
that could perpetuate structural racism. It is
very tragic to see how its enforcement led to
the incarceration of young black Americans.
And again, that punitive system where someone
could be stopped, and this will happen if you are
black and on the notion that you had drugs with
you and thrown in jail or prison because you had
drugs on you is such an unfair system. And it
didn't work in any way because it did not reduce
the amount of drugs that people were taking or
the negative consequences of drugs to our society.
So it did not work.
And I think, and too, I mean one
of the aspects that it did show is if you do
throw a person that's taking drugs in jail,
if you criminalize that person that's
using drugs, for example, when we did
horribly with crack cocaine. So if you
were smoking crack cocaine, it was like,
I don't recall exactly, but it was at least 10
times greater than if you were just snorting
cocaine. Snorting cocaine or injecting cocaine
hydrochloride was much more favored by white
people. Whereas crack was favored by black people.
So cocaine hydrochloride, white, crack cocaine,
black. Why do you see such a difference? It's
the same cocaine, basically. Cocaine is cocaine,
and yet one could note a much higher penalty than
the other. That's an example of the consequences.
But what science has shown is that when you do
throw people into jail or prisons that have a
problem with substance use disorders, then when
they leave, they are at much greater risk of,
first of all, relapsing immediately into the
drug taking and escalating their drug taking.
So you are exacerbating the nature of the
problem by putting them in jail and prison.
So it doesn't work no matter what you do. And
that's why the whole notion of criminalizing
the person that takes drugs is basically very
negative vis-a-vis the outcomes of the person
and also in no way it benefits society,
it is actually very costly by itself.
When an issue becomes politicized, then it
becomes much harder to change and shift.
And we've seen, I think, that we've
seen over the past, I would say,
certainly, five or eight years, an openness to
recognizing that the War on Drugs did not work
and that criminalizing drug users is basically
negative and it's promoting structural racism.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to cover quite a
few things and I would like to get to
harm reduction, but I'd like to do that a little
bit later and to hear your perspectives on that.
First, I wanted to go from the problems that
you've described to looking at pushing the limits,
daring to do things, some of the perhaps novel
or developing potential approaches to treating
addiction. And there are several things I'd
like to talk about. Certainly you have recently,
I want to say, written about TMS and deep brain
stimulation. I would like to talk about those.
First, I thought we might speak about psychedelics
and psychedelic-assisted therapy and I wanted to
congratulate and thank you for being one
of the first, if not the first institute
director to fund psychedelic research with
humans after the scientific winter following
the Nixon administration, which interestingly
enough, at least I've read that some of the
Controlled Substance Act and Nixon's decisions
around that were motivated by controlling
certain demographics or having the pretense
of being able to search and seize and so on.
That was from, I think it was Ehrlichman
in his — it might not have been cabinet,
but sort of inner circle. But coming
back to the treatment side of things,
could you speak to perhaps what we know
already about psychedelics as treatments?
What is interesting and what milestones — I
think this is a question on a lot of minds
and you're very qualified to speak to this. What
milestones still need to be reached to instill
confidence in these drugs as therapeutics?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yeah. And I think it's a
very interesting, potentially promising area of
therapeutics, but the evidence is, the way that I
see it is the evidence that exists is very limited
but is sufficiently intriguing actually that you
cannot ignore it and behooves you in terms of
why we are identifying this as a priority area of
research in the whole issue of psychotherapeutics,
of the use of psychedelic drugs.
The data is strongest for the use of psilocybin
for depression, particularly for — I mean studies
have shown, and I think that even though the
sample sizes are not very large, they have
consistently shown to improve the outcomes on
patients with terminal illnesses. Most of them,
I think if I recall correctly, were with cancer in
whom the psilocybin allowed them to accept better
emotionally the fact that this was a terminal
illness and improved their depression scores.
And that was quite significant. There's also data
showing the potential for, and that was for PTSD,
the use of psychedelic drugs. So this may be the
two disease conditions for which that there's
more data. The clinical trials are limited in
sample sizes and in numbers, but the effect sizes
are significant despite the small sample sizes.
There are some studies that have been done in
substance use disorder. Nicotine is one of them.
Alcohol use disorders, alcoholism is another one.
And again, both of them are on psilocybin. And for
both of them, there is also this positive effect.
And what's intriguing and speaking about it
in terms of the nicotine is that the effects
actually appear to be larger than the ones
that you see with medications that we used
for the treatment of nicotine dependence, just
like Chantix or nicotine replacement therapies.
So the number of people that stopped smoking is
actually significantly greater than that, that is
the percentage that stops smoking with medications
that have been approved by the FDA. But a study
number one, only one study and the sample sizes
are small. So that's why we are funding the
researchers. This is a group at Johns Hopkins
University to actually replicate that study.
So the data is quite interesting, but it is very
preliminary, and I do want to emphasize this
because sort of people like to make conclusions
before the evidence is out there. And my concern
is that, and you already see it, you go into
the web and there's a lot of sites advertising
treatments with psychedelic drugs, not just
for mental illnesses but also for well-being
when the data is not there. And so we don't know,
first of all, if first we need to replicate what,
but assume that you replicate and it does
work, what are the doses, how to give it,
what are potential negative side effects?
I mean, what clinical trials have reported
is in a small number of people, there
is a risk of suicidal behaviors and
suicidality. So who is at risk to show
that? Actually if you start to see it,
how can you prevent it? Should you administer the
psychedelic drug? It has been believed that the
psychedelic drug is adjunctive therapy, that it
is the interaction with a therapist while you're
under the influence of the psychedelic drug, that
it is therapeutic. That's one of the hypothesis.
So how you should be administering, how do
psychotherapists gets involved? And all of these
are scientific questions that we need to basically
explore with research because we don't have
the data there that is needed to build up.
And if we don't build up and people start to
use it and they start to have negative effects
like suicides, then that can lead to actually
jeopardizing the future use of these medications.
The FDA may say, "This is too dangerous," or
the DEA may say, "This is too dangerous. We
are not going to agree to its utilization."
And that is where the danger comes around
of pushing something to preliminary.
Tim Ferriss: I agree that certainly the
positioning of psychedelics as panacea, which we
see a lot, is really putting the cart before the
horse in a lot of ways. And there are risks, which
is why there are exclusionary criteria at places
like Johns Hopkins for certain conditions, whether
it's schizophrenia or bipolar disorder or others.
And I'd love to chat a little bit about study
design and what researchers might do or consider
to make their studies and grant applications more
appealing to institutes like NIDA. And the reason
that I'd love to explore that a bit is many smart
scientists are now paying attention to this,
including younger scientists who are considering
this as a career focus. And as it stands right
now, there's a very small pool of serious
independent philanthropists or foundations
who are providing funding. It's very small.
I would say it may be in the 15- to
20-person range, really when we're
looking at anyone donating above a hundred
thousand dollars a year. It's very small.
And then on the other hand, you have, and I
think there's a role certainly, an important
role for market-based, for-profit solutions and
providers, but you have sponsored research on
the other end of the spectrum. And NIDA has
been very forward-looking in the sense that
you've provided funding to Dr. Matt Johnson and
so on at Hopkins looking at nicotine addiction.
I would love to know, and I'll
just provide a little bit more
thought. I know this is going to be a very long
question and then to get your thoughts on what
people might do to make their applications or
studies more appealing. One of the challenges
is certainly that is brought up oftentimes is
blinding. And these studies or these compounds
and the experiences associated are really highly
discriminable in the sense that most people
know they are either in the control group or not.
And you have potential active placebos and people
have experimented with niacin. Some people have
considered higher doses of, say, cannabinoids, but
it's difficult it seems to find lookalike drugs
that do not also bring similar actions or effects.
Do you think there's a place for, say,
comparative efficacy studies where you might have,
by analogy, psychotherapy versus X, right?
The people who are getting psychotherapy are going
to be aware they're getting psychotherapy, but you
could compare it with another therapy where you
could compare psilocybin for, say, nicotine
addiction to nicotine replacement therapy.
Those are just a couple of, I
suppose, a bit of connective tissue
for people who may not have more context.
But what would you like scientists to pay
attention to? What would you implore them to try
to do with their studies and designs if they want
to try to get more federal funding?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Well, I think that,
I mean certainly you've discussed, and there's
no simple solutions of how difficult it is to
control for a placebo, but it is an important
one. So one of the recommendations is to use a
very low dose of the psychedelic drug. So you're
giving them the psychedelic drug, but a dose that
is considered to be subtherapeutic. And that's
what some of the researchers are doing right now.
And to follow all of the guidelines and practices
when you're going to be doing a randomized
clinical trial, which are the ones that you
basically divide participants. Some get the active
intervention, others do not, and you randomize
it and you follow them. And that's the way that
you actually collect data that then allows you
to determine if there is a difference or not.
But I think that the grantees that are coming up
with proposals know these, I mean, how to propose
one of the randomized clinical trials. One of the
things that we work with grantees too, which is
important, is that we help them in terms of the
interactions with the FDA because the FDA at the
end of the day is the one that's going to be able
to say what data do they need in order to be able
to consider that a clinical trial is done in a
way that they make it feel comfortable to approve
an indication for a psychedelic drug or not.
So it is crucial that they work from beginning
as they are planning to do their clinical
trial, that they engage with the FDA and we
absolutely help them. I mean, we try to provide
them support if the FDA, for example, wants them
to do toxicology X or toxicology Y or look at the
biodistribution. There are certain things that
we can, through our contracts, help them obtain.
And we are specifically requesting this, and I'm
speaking right now of clinical trials of grantees.
There may be other scientific questions that are
very valid that are not just a randomized clinical
trial that we also would be very interested
on funding. For example, with brain imaging,
you can now look at how, and there was a paper.
There's one paper that actually looks at the
effects of psilocybin. I think it was psilocybin.
Either LSD or psilocybin, I don't recall.
And you're looking at, we have these brain
networks that interact with one another, and
what they showed was that that architecture
of network was significantly disrupted during
the hallucination state when the drug was on
board. And so if you can, I mean, do research
that can identify biomarkers of the effects of
the psychedelic drug, that's one area that is
interesting. But also through those studies,
can you understand the mechanisms that are
responsible for the therapeutic benefits.
So by looking at how the brain changes its
operations, and then you can determine if
that is associated with therapeutic benefit, you
can start to understand mechanisms of actions of
psychedelic drugs. We're also funding researchers
to develop, we know what the psychedelic drugs
that we currently have, but with chemistry, you
can create other psychedelic drugs, for example,
that may have the same pharmacological target,
but they don't produce hallucinatory experiences,
that which will make it much
easier to actually implement.
So we are interested in a whole gamut of research
that could help advance our understanding of the
potential of psychedelic drugs for therapeutics.
Tim Ferriss: The entire category of sort of
non-hallucinatory psychedelic compounds is very
interesting. I think there appear to be some
very interesting indications that might be really
favorable targets for these, what are sometimes
called the psychoplastogens, like cluster
headaches in the case of LSD or LSD analogs.
What would you make, and the answer could be
that they're mistaken of researchers who report
based on all the documentation from subjects
in these various studies, whether at UCSF.
And I think the imaging that you were mentioning
may be Robin Carhart-Harris and his team,
because they do a lot of functional MRI and
imaging looking at the perhaps increased entropy
or connectivity or both communication-wise in the
brain on these experiences. Anyway, in that case
it would be psilocybin. And what would you make
potentially of the importance of meaning making?
And that is to say beyond the activity signature
that you can track or the receptor affinity the
reports from subjects that it's the meaning making
in these sessions, which seem to be, in part,
hand in hand with the hallucinations, the
psychedelic experience relating to how they
see themselves and the world that lead to the
behavioral change in the durability of some of
these effects rather than dendritic spine growth
or any number of changes that you can observe.
But given that, say, the duration of some of these
sessions is four to six hours, let's just say, and
the half-life is pretty short, but some of the
effects seem to be quite durable with, say, the
existential distress in terminal
cancer patients and also for nicotine.
Is there a way to include those factors as an area
of inquiry in addition to the sort of mechanistic
studies and the basic science and the imaging?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Of course, and there's been
actually papers that have done that, that
actually have looked at the association
between the intensity of the subjective
experience and their therapeutic benefits,
and then have shown that those that have the
more intense mystical experience had, the better
therapeutic response. But that element of meaning
and understanding is basically not in any way
exclusionary with that of neuroplasticity, because
it may be that in fact, that that experience
that you have there while you are living it
under the effect of the hallucinogenic drug,
may generate a longer lasting memory
because of those neuroplastic effects.
And again, highlighting why that combination
of the drug itself with the psychotherapeutic
intervention becomes crucial. So you cannot
certainly separate them. But to me, if we can, if
it can be corroborating that there is this
neuroplasticity and will learn to use it properly,
then imagine how extraordinary it is to be able to
generate a window in time whereby exposing you to
stimuli under the effect of the psychedelic
drug, if it, in fact, turns to be the case,
you could strengthen a particular memory and
that would allow you to actually cover a memory
that may be very painful. So you are competing one
memory against the other. So I think that this is,
to me, one of the most fascinating areas about
why I think that these psychedelic drugs deserve
attention for research because to have a
means to monitor, to accelerate learning and
memory process, this neuroplasticity, long-term
potentiation phenomena that we've been studying
in neuroscience could be a very powerful tool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's been very exciting to be
involved with some of the early-stage science and
to see it develop over time and to also have a lot
of misgivings about the public discussion
when it veers into the land of panacea,
because these things are absolutely not panacea
and they're very, I believe, powerful compounds
based on the data that we have so far.
One more question, maybe two more questions
about this, and then I would love to move to
TMS, which I am increasingly fascinated by.
I was a subject in a study involving TMS a
long time ago, but the technology was pretty
primitive then. My question is about substance
use disorders, and if in the very preliminary,
but very preliminary hypothesis that psychedelics
and specifically psilocybin, so the same molecule
appears to have effects across drugs of abuse
meaning or potential abuse, so if you have, let's
say the work of Michael Bogenschutz and others at
NYU looking at alcohol use disorder, psilocybin,
then you have Dr. Matt Johnson and nicotine.
You also have people like Peter Hendricks
looking at cocaine. If, let me not say if,
well no, I'll use if. If It turns out that
those can be replicated, we can hopefully,
and I'm very optimistic that there'll be
more federal funding for these things
because there is a bit of a chicken and
the egg problem in terms of sample size and
funding availability, which is challenging.
But what could it mean if it turns out that
something like psilocybin is effective across
multiple compounds? Is that common, I simply
don't know, in other sort of frontline treatments,
or would that be something novel that
would raise very interesting questions
in your mind about the nature of addiction?
Dr. Nora Volkow: I've been studying as a
researcher multiple addictions. I mean cocaine,
alcohol, methamphetamine, nicotine, and more
recently opioids and heroin also. I've been
intrigued about what do all of these addictions
have in common. In fact, I've been intrigued about
what something like morbid obesity has in common
with addiction if you look at the brain.
Because they all share as a common
phenomenological presentation, the compulsiveness
of the behavior and the loss of self-regulation.
So you cannot stop it and you just basically
escalate on that behavior. So I've been intrigued
about recognizing the common elements in the
brain and then of course also studying their
uniqueness. The neurocircuitry is basically very
similar. What is different is the way that you
engage it. So to me it in and of itself, it's
not surprising that you have a therapeutic that
is going to be valuable for multiple addictions.
And we're funding other types of research with
other molecules with the aim of basically
targeting just a medication for addiction in
general so that we could also start to address
the problem of poly-substance addictions that
we have without having to just go specific.
So it doesn't, per se, surprise me. What I
would be very intrigued in that notion is if we
were to understand the mechanism and the common
mechanism across all of the addictions is that you
create long-term potentiation in reward circuits.
So you're strengthening the signaling on
systems that basically are associating the
drug with pleasure and reward and you are
weakening the signaling that's associating
pleasure and reinforcement for other stimulant and
reward. So just actually a strengthening process
and a weakening processing. And you generate it in
such a way that you've created an artificial need
for the drug, just like you have a need for food,
now you have an artificial need for the drug.
And I'm very much intrigued about the similarities
with pain. When you have pain where the insult is
no longer there, but the memory of that pain
continues making you feel it just like in the
addicted person, the memory of the pleasure leads
you to continue wanting it. So it's not just that
I think it could be beneficial for different types
of drugs, but I do think there's value in actually
even considering the extent to which, if there
are shown to be able to modify neuroplasticity,
treatments for this chronic pain conditions
which are devastating and for which we really
don't have anything — I mean, not that I know
that there's much research into it, but I'm
just telling you where my brain is jumping into.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely. So a few things
come to mind. If you haven't looked at the work of
Gül Dölen, G-U-L, D-O-L-E-N, she's at Hopkins, her
perspective is quite different from, say, Robin
Carhart-Harris, and I think she has some very
interesting hypotheses around these reopening of
critical windows with respect to, say, plasticity.
Then on the chronic pain topic, I will say
and this was done at an above board, very well
run clinic with proper medical supervision,
but I went through two weeks of
ketamine infusion several years ago, not because
I was depressed, but because I wanted to be able
to speak firsthand to the experience because I
knew I would have a lot of questions about it
from friends and also audience and
so on. I'm not a doctor, I don't
play one on the internet just to be very clear.
But what was fascinating to me is I went in having
read a lot of the research related to depression,
and I've since had Dr. John Krystal from Yale on
the show to have a very long conversation about
all things ketamine. What I didn't realize though,
when I went in because I was not going in
with any severe depression or I couldn't have
anticipated what happened, and that was for me, I
had chronic back pain in my mid thoracic back from
a longstanding injury which was very severe.
Had daily pain and intense pain for
10 years, let's call it. And when I left
my two weeks of infusions, I had no back
pain for about six months. And it turns out
one of other primary indications is chronic
pain. There's a lot to recommend psilocybin
over ketamine at psychedelic dosing, but
it matches very well with what you were saying
about the potential overlap of plasticity and
not just for indications like depression,
but also for something like chronic pain.
Dr. Nora Volkow: I wasn't thinking of ketamine.
I mean, ketamine is not considered, as you know,
a classical psychedelic drug, but there is a
lot of work on research ongoing for the value of
ketamine for the treatment of chronic pain. What
I would like to sort of look, and I look at it
in terms of what has been done, because again, all
of these areas, they're investigated but I'm going
to check it out because want to see if anyone has
published anything on psilocybin for chronic pain.
I was jumping into the classical psychedelics
which have very different mechanisms of actions
than ketamine, but absolutely ketamine. I
think ketamine was that drug that let us open
up the doors to say, here we have a drug that is a
dissociative type of drug that is also a drug that
can produce addiction, a classical psychedelic
stone, and yet, despite everybody's prejudices,
show to be beneficial for treatment of depression.
So I think that that is an example about why we
cannot just close our eyes and say no. We need to
look at these classical psychedelics. So I would
like — you made me now curious about it.
Tim Ferriss: Also, the fact, as you were
mentioning earlier, that there is room
for potentially stripping out some of the
psychedelic effects. I think we need to keep
in mind that the business motivations may not
always be aligned with clinical outcomes. Of
course it would be much more convenient to
work with these compounds if they didn't elicit
the types of hallucinations we've discussed.
But even something that is a non-classical
psychedelic, let's say Salvinorin A, so you
have a kappa-opioid agonist, may have some really
interesting applications for minimizing damage
after stroke, for vascular problems. Super, super
fascinating, of course more research is needed.
So I wanted to shift to TMS and deep brain
stimulation and this is very interesting to me.
We were talking about sort of different activity
or maybe pathological activity in different neuro
anatomical structures. I don't know if the nucleus
accumbens fits into both that prior discussion and
the TMS and deep brain stimulation, but could
you speak to what TMS is, what deep brain
stimulation is, and why they are of interest?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Oh, they're incredibly
interesting and I'm going to introduce you
to a new technology that has my brain even
more excited than TMS. TMS goes for transcranial
magnetic stimulation and it's a technology that
is not invasive. You actually administer
magnetic currents in the scalp and then
these magnetic currents actually go
into the cortex of the brain and they
are signal transferred as electrical signals.
And it can be used to modulate either at high
frequencies to stimulate or lower frequencies
to inhibit the areas that you are targeting.
By understanding how in the cortex — the brain
is a very complicated network and so it links
with almost everything else, but there are hubs,
there are areas that act as hubs. That is they
have many more connections. Some of them go deep
into the brain. So as you understand better that
pattern of connectivity, you can deliver
TMS in such a way that you can start to
reach areas that are deeper in the brain,
which are very important for diseases of
depression and diseases of certainly addiction.
I mean you were speaking about the nucleus
accumbens, which is the main reward region of the
brain and all of the drugs of abuse, all of them
stimulate it. When you stimulate it in animals
with electrical currents or with optogenetics,
you generate rewarding signals. The transcranial
magnetic stimulation cannot reach deep,
but you can reach it indirectly. That's what
they use it and it's a technology that's
approved for the treatment of depression.
Deep brain stimulation then basically is an
invasive procedure. You put the electrodes inside
the brain and it's being used, for example, for
treatment of addiction research. It's being used
for research, also treatment of depression and
other diseases. And the nucleus accumbens is one
of the main targets both for depression as well as
for addiction. But there are other neuromodulation
technologies, so transcranial magnetic, the other
one is direct electrical current stimulation,
which instead of giving magnetic signals from
the outside, you give the electrical pulses.
But the one that I am very intrigued, and I want
to actually introduce you to if you haven't heard
about it, is low-intensity ultrasound. So it uses
ultrasound and you can use it with high-intensity
or low-intensity and you apply it on the outside
of the brain. If you use high-intensity, you
can very specifically create an ablation. So
you can do what you could do with surgery, but
very precisely without having to open the head.
But that's high-intensity. The beauty of the
low-intensity is you do not produce damage
to the tissue, but you can modify it for a
long time. So they are doing research right
now and they basically approve — actually, the
high-intensity ultrasound was recently approved
for Parkinson's disease and they are now doing —
Tim Ferriss: This is the high-intensity?
Dr. Nora Volkow: The high-intensity, but the
researchers are looking at low-intensity for
neurological diseases and for addiction and
other mental illnesses. The beauty is that sound
goes through the tissue so you can target
the nucleus accumbens directly with a
much greater precision than with
transcranial magnetic stimulation.
Tim Ferriss: That's super interesting.
Dr. Nora Volkow: It's fascinating. And you
need to apply it for 10 minutes. The pilot data is
showing that you see it for, say, the effects are
two weeks or four weeks with a single stimulation.
Tim Ferriss: With a single session of 10 minutes?
Dr. Nora Volkow: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Dr. Nora Volkow: The pilot data is very —
Tim Ferriss: That's very interesting.
Dr. Nora Volkow: It's pilot data, sort of. That's
why I say, now that you're speaking to me and last
time we spoke, I'm very excited of TMS. I'm not
in any way going to minimize it, but actually
what I like so much, and I'm just going to say
what you push the limit and I said, "Let's push
our own thinking." If you are able to do this
long-lasting effect as you learn to understand
better how these frequencies for ultrasound
stimulation affect the tissue, I think that
one day we may be able to cure addiction. No one
has ever heard me speak about curing addiction.
Why do I think it is possible? Because we know
that when people have strokes in certain areas
of the brain, particularly frequently involving
the insula, there are cases where people just
stop taking the drug. They forget about taking
the drug, they don't care anymore about it. So
there's been instances which have shown that
the insult, a stroke in a particular area,
cures the person of their addiction.
So what about if we gain that knowledge
about what are the relevant circuits and areas,
and we have the tools now to manipulate them in
ways that are much more effective than we had
in the past, that opens up the possibility in
the future that we may be able to cure addiction.
Tim Ferriss: Well, that makes me feel much more
optimistic. I also feel like at some point, and
I'm getting ahead of myself, but looking at these
novel cutting edge technologies, or in some
cases very old technologies like psilocybin
being applied to conditions in novel ways
that at some point there might be poly
therapies that combine some of these factors.
Let me ask you a question about the Parkinson's
for a second though, because I have Parkinson's
on one, I think, but now both sides of my family,
so it's of intense interest. If they're using high
frequency, and for those who don't know the term,
ablation, and I want you to please correct
me if I'm wrong, but that can be surgical
removal of tissue or I suppose destruction
of tissue, might be another way to put it,
I want you to correct my definition if
I'm getting it wrong, but how would that
strength of effect be used in Parkinson's?
Dr. Nora Volkow: It is the high-intensity
ultrasound and the high-intensity ultrasound
becomes ablative. So you are targeting, for
example, the subthalamic nuclei just like you do
with surgery, but in this case you're not opening
it up and you can very precisely damage it.
This brings psychosurgery to a completely new
level. And so they applied it. I think that
one of the targets is a subthalamic nuclei,
but I also think that they targeted parts of a
very small nuclei in the thalamus too. So it is
fascinating also from that perspective in
instances where psychosurgery may be valuable,
that you can do it as minimally invasive
and as precisely and in as small an area
as possible. So I think it's quite remarkable.
Tim Ferriss: Now you've got me all excited about
this low-intensity ultrasound. I've been following
the TMS pretty closely, and in particular the
shorter duration, higher-frequency dosing of TMS.
So let's just say multiple sessions a day over the
span of five days, there's some interesting work
being done. I know the plural of anecdote does not
equal data, but anecdotally I've seen a number of
outcomes with friends' children who are patients
that have practically just defied belief.
But on the low-intensity ultrasound side,
you mentioned, and we'll put links in the show
notes for people and maybe I'll get some links
from you or your team just where people can
learn more about this. I know it's pilot data,
so kind of hold your horses, the jury's still out.
But nonetheless, very interesting place to begin.
In addition to the durability that you
were mentioning, which I think was two to
four weeks, let's just say after a single
10-minute session, is the onset of effect
immediate or near immediate as well?
Dr. Nora Volkow: It's basically almost immediate.
One of the consistent findings that they're seeing
is that they see a reduction in anxiety, they see
a reduction in craving. It's pilot work. I want
to reiterate that, it needs to be replicated, but
when I saw that pilot data, I said, "Oh, my God."
It was the group at West Virginia who has been
doing basically the deep brain stimulation for the
treatment of opioid addiction. They insert these
electrodes and then they've basically observed
that in three of the four individuals that they've
treated on that pilot study, basically they were
able to, again, very dramatically reduce anxiety,
and they decreased the consumption of opioids.
So it showed a positive effect in three of four.
I mean, they basically told me these effects that
we are getting with a low-intensity ultrasound
that they've tested eight people are as
dramatic or more dramatic than when we're
seeing with basically the deep brain stimulation
of the nucleus accumbens. So they target also the
nucleus accumbens with low-intensity ultrasound.
So it is very intriguing. I'm a scientist and I
love and I get excited with data, but I do want to
iterate, it's very pilot. It's very, very pilot,
but it has to be studied. It's like with what
we were saying with the psychedelic drugs,
it's very interesting, it has to be studied.
Tim Ferriss: Everything starts small. Almost
everything starts small. We all start with
the pilots, so the jury is still out. But
it's exciting that you're pushing the limits
and you're daring to push the envelope and
experiment with new things, of course. I mean,
that's part of the charter, but you also have a
history of doing this well, and I don't think you
would've arrived where you are today had you not
been very dogged and determined. It just goes
all the way back to when you were turned down
by NIDA and here you are as the director. It's
just remarkable. It's just a remarkable story.
So Dr. Volkow, you've been very generous with
your time. I've enjoyed the conversation. I
could keep going for another two hours, no
problem, but you have an incredibly busy
schedule. Is there anything else that you
would like to share with people out there?
Any requests to my audience? Anything at all that
you would like to say before we wind to a close?
Dr. Nora Volkow: There are two things that I
would have liked to add. One of them is that
addiction is very frequently comorbid with
other psychiatric disorders, and most notable
is anxiety, depression, suicidality. This, I
bring it up, because you need to address these
comorbid conditions. Because otherwise, it's
not going to be possible for the person to be
able to recover. And also, from the perspective
that, if you are depressed, if you're anxious,
if you are suicidal, you are likely to take drugs
as a mean to automedicate, to escape that mental
state. And it is crucial to send this message,
because actually, it's not as simple as saying
that "You take drugs because you want to get
high and you're taking the drugs." People are
taking the drugs to, many times, initially, yes,
for curiosity or, many times, to feel good. But
once you become addicted, it is really to escape
a mental state that is very difficult to stay at.
It's very, in a way, very painful. And the other
point that I did want to bring too, that we
haven't discussed, which is, in understanding how
we understand the effects of drugs and addiction
and how we understand also mental illness, is
how important the environmental factors are and
how crucial they are, particularly when you're
a child or an adolescence. I think that we've
all become much more sensitized to them with
the COVID pandemic, because we came to realize
that there are certain people that were at much
greater disadvantage, and that's those people that
are in circumstances of economic inequality,
of trauma during childhood, and what we call
the social determinants of health, that are
really playing very important roles in people's
encounter with drugs and how they respond to
it and how they ultimately also maybe given an
opportunity or not to access treatment
and too how they respond to treatment.
So as you were speaking, for example, with
psychedelic drugs, we are very concerned that,
if, as psychedelic therapist, if they basically
get into mainstay clinical practice, if they're
proven to be useful, that they are equitable and
they doesn't end up with, like many of the very
fancy treatments that we have now, that are
only accessible to a very few. So that's the
only other thing that I would want to say.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, 100 percent agreed on
both. And that's also part of the reason
that I hope we will see, whether it's
with psychedelic therapies, psychedelic
assisted therapies, or other modalities,
in some cases, options for group treatment and at
least the testing of the hypothesis that outcomes
can not only be equal to individual treatment,
but potentially, even better. And I think there
is the possibility that that is the case, which
would also have the wonderful side effect of
decreasing costs, quite significantly. And there's
so many questions of insurance reimbursement and,
ultimately, reclassification, which would be sort
of a precursor to a lot of these things happening.
But I agree with you, absolutely completely. And
it's also as upsetting and pessimistic as one
can become when they look at the compounding
of many of the addiction problems in the US.
I feel like we are at a point in history also,
with some of these burgeoning technologies,
as you mentioned. And I think it was obvious in
the excitement in your voice. There are things
potentially on the horizon that could really
change how we, not only treat addiction, but how
we think about addiction as well, which is very
exciting and I think cause for a certain degree of
cautious optimism.
Dr. Nora Volkow: Oh,
yes. I'm very optimistic, Tim, and I'm
going to abandon you at this point. I'm
going to jump off that screen, but it's
been a pleasure speaking with you.